on commence donc par s'intéresser au cas
de viktor orban le parti populaire
européen le ppe qui est le grand parti
de droite représentée au parlement à
strasbourg et à bruxelles va décider cet
après midi si le suspens s'il exclut ou
s'il maintient viktor orban dans ses
rangs alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui a provoqué cette cette
réunion au cours de laquelle 261
délégués vont voter pour que cette
décision et bien c'est cette campagne
regardez cette affiche
vous y voyez george soros le financier
international vous y voyez aussi jean
claude juncker et si vous ne parlez pas
le hongrois je vous traduis ce cas sur
la fiche vous aussi avez le droit de
savoir ce que bruxelles vous prépare et
ce que bruxelles prépare selon jacques
selon viktor orban pardon c'est une
arrivée massive de migrants et d'imposer
des réfugiés sur le territoire hongrois
le problème c'est que jean claude
juncker n'est pas seulement le patron de
la commission européenne c'est aussi
l'un des leaders du ppe d'où le courroux
de ce parti alors est-ce que
or ban pour l'ensemble de son oeuvre est
un leader de droite comme les autres ce
qui mérite d'être exclu vous allez me
dire ce que vous en pensez mais je
voudrais si vous le voulez bien écouter
un des membres éminents du fan-club de
viktor orban
c'est philippe de villiers philippe de
villiers aux auditeurs de sud radio hier
expliquait une conversation qu'il avait
eue avec or ban
et voilà ce que rebelle lui avait dit il
me reproche d'avoir inscrit dans la
constitution les racines chrétiennes de
la hongrie saint-etienne il me reproche
d'avoir dit qu'un ensemble de avoir un
père et une mère et il me reproche
d'avoir accordé aux hongrois dans la
constitution le droit de protéger leurs
frontières
et pendant ce temps là vous leur de
bruxelles m réprimande parce que je
bloque la frontière et el pais erdogan
le turc elle paye 6 milliards d'euros
par an pour bloquer la sienne pour faire
de la rétention de migrants parce qu'on
n'est pas capables nous de défendre
notre propre frontière
quel symbole voilà donc en fait j'ai
pendant trois heures et demie je me suis
dit mais cet homme là il est remarquable
et on vous pose la question sur twitter
viktor orban est il un leader de droite
comme les autres questions assez ouverte
indique effectivement on peut mettre
beaucoup de choses derrière ça et vous
ne répondez oui mais à 55 % donc c'est
relativement partagés philippe temps on
n'a pas encore la décision d'aider du
ppe me semble-t-il sauf si vous vous
lavez de votre côté donc ils sont encore
en train de se réunir ou de voter nos
amis mais sur le fond est ce que est ce
que hors banner est un conservateur
comme les autres pour faire court je
pense que oui et je pense que ça suffit
c'est quelqu'un qui provoque à longueur
de ton qui va à l'encontre de l'union
européenne je vous rappelle que le pays
fait partie intégrale de l'union
européenne donc il ya comme des règles à
respecter et il a décidé de ne pas les
respecter
il ya quand même des quotas des migrants
qu'ils devaient accepter il va refuser
et là je viens longtemps d'aujourd'hui
qu'il est en train de donner des prix à
des gens qui sont le terme on antisémite
donc cesser c'est quelqu'un qui fait
tout en son pouvoir pro provoquer
l'union européenne avec ses affiches à
chaumont nauséabond et je pense qu'il
est temps de frapper une fois pour
toutes sur la table pour dénonçant
suffit maintenant vous êtes exclu du ppp
le seul problème avec cette exclusion
c'est que quelque part je pense que
robin ne le cherche il le veut il veut
provoquer une ont peiné veut faire
quelque chose et me fait du bruit du
base vous pensez qu'il veut être viré du
je pense que là s'il se fait virer
il va se dire voilà je suis pas compris
je deviens martyrs de de ce que je crois
parce que l'union européenne c'est comme
insectes ils n'acceptent pas donc voilà
il essaye de créer le buzz et de
peut-être aussi agrandir son soutien par
les mouvements populistes texte en boîte
c'était n'importe où en europe car
chartier qu'est-ce que vecteur hörmann
finalement il veut avoir des frontières
très protégé il veut faire une politique
familiale c'est assez classique pour un
pour un dirigeant de droite n'ont alors
à mon sens plus qu'un dirigeant de
droite c'est surtout un populiste
d'opportunisme parce qu'il faut se
souvenir que hörmann à l'origine était
un libéral et puis il a vu qu'il aurait
pas de place dans l'élite qu'ils se
constituaient après le régime communiste
qui se mettait en place et qui a assuré
la transition démocratique vers la haye
le marché l'économie de marché mais qui
s'est dit là j'ai pas de placer comme il
est fin politique parce que ce qu'on
peut pas lui ôter c'est ça il s'est dit
bah tiens je vais prendre une autre voie
et cette voie ça a été celle de la
hongrie rural des petites villes celles
d'une hongrie conservatrice et
identitaire
mais c'était à mon sens plus un calcul
politique d'après ce que nous rapportent
des observateurs sur le terrain
plus qu'une conviction départ donc c'est
pour ça que je parle d' opportunisme
maintenant je rejoins assez
cette idée c'est à dire qu'il ya
probablement un calcul là dedans parce
que c'est vrai que les provocations sont
quand même très très récurrentes et
qu'on peut se demander s'il ne veut pas
constituer un front européen précisément
dont il serait la figure de proue
populiste et donc emmener des gens comme
en italie en fin d'année cette vie n'est
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il avait
rencontré l été dernier enfin emmener
tous ces gens là dans un groupe en
europe pour faire vraiment pièce à la
droite plus classiques dont il ne veut
plus le problème c'est que je pense
qu'on fait effectivement très bien de
alors je ne sais pas quelle sera la
décision en tout cas je rejoins
complètement cette idée qu'il faut
mettre un coup d'arrêt à cela parce que
sinon pour la droite européenne
plus classique c'est accepter quand même
une vision de la démocratie qui est
extrêmement pernicieuse parce qu'on l'a
déjà beaucoup dit mais ce viktor orban
fait il a théorisé ce concept de
démocratie libérale qui veut dire quoi
qui veut dire que la démocratie
finalement repose entièrement sur la
souveraineté du peuple et le
gouvernement est censé incarner à lui
tout seul la souveraineté du peuple
or que fait urban en hongrie il s'assoit
il a mis sous tutelle
en fait le ministère de la justice et il
est en train de faire la même chose avec
les universités donc c'est accepter
cette conception de la démocratie je
pense que c'est extrêmement périlleux à
l'heure à laquelle nous sommes de
tension et de remises en question de
même d'une validité de l'état
démocratique
vraiment je pense qu'à un coup d'arrêt à
m des regrets si vous étiez député
européen membre du ppe qu'est ce que
vous feriez suspension exclusion ou
statu quo alors moi je n'ai je ne
partage pas l'avis qui vient d'être
développé jeu là vous pourrez étendre à
la peau à la question initiale est il un
dirigeant de droite comme les autres en
tout cas il est un dirigeant de droite
tels que un certain nombre d'électeurs
en europe et même de nombreux électeurs
et en france il faudrait le dire
appellent de leurs voeux c'est un fait
parce que est bien seul philippe de
villiers l'a développé assez de façon
assez synthétique ses positions sur la
famille sa vision jugée un peu plus
réaliste que bien d'autres dirigeants
sur l'immigration et bien satisfait un
certain nombre d'électeurs est en effet
ils jouent ce créneau là il l'a 10
vent il dit moi j'écoute mes électeurs
et je défends la hongrie avant de
défendre l'europe et c'est bien ce que
reproche
actuellement les populistes à leurs
dirigeants et je crois que la sanction
c'est le choix que les professeurs et
les gardiens de prisons savent ça quand
il ya un niveau de révolte qui atteint
ça se manie comme de la nitroglycérine
c'est à dire que s'ils le font partir et
bien comme vous le disiez il sera un
martyr et galvanisera les tièdes et puis
consciente israël et ceux qui n'étaient
pas les indifférents et puis s'est en
revanche pas s'il reste en effet il y
aura peut-être une contagion et on se
dira tout est permis dans ce groupe donc
là je crois que c'est c'est quelque
chose de d'extrêmement crucial mais en
tout cas si le vire pour parler
vulgairement
je pense que ce sera vraiment une
victoire à la pyrrhus alors figurez-vous
que peut-être que les gens du ppe sont
en train de regarder point de vue parce
que selon nos confrères de l'agencé
reuters les dirigeants du parti voudrait
gagner du temps créer un comité qui
irait en hongrie pour s'assurer que
l'état de droit est respecté comme il
convient et puis je vous donne certains
des réactions de nos internautes qui
semble apprécier viktor orban sur
lefigaro.fr nicole nous dit le ppe comme
son nom l'indiqué populaire donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi la hongrie devrait
quitter ce groupe est la même dit qu
elle ajoute c'est un leader de droit
pour moi or bahn je dirais même mieux
que certains car il défend son pays
johan audel a une politique
d'immigration ferme est ce interdit pour
l'interrogation et r34 en quoi espérer
messieurs de respecter les vues du
peuple c'est vrai qu'on peut dire que
victor ans ban a été élu et réélu est
assez largement les contre-pouvoirs
aussi je veux dire c'est pas un leader
de droite classique la dhr on vient les
valeurs d'autorité de sécurité terrasson
des valeurs de droite classique
là il va beaucoup plus loin c'est autre
chose il s'assoit quand même sur des
contre-pouvoirs qui assure pour compte
ils ces institutions ont elles été créé
c'est pour précisément empêcher les
dérives autoritaires d'un exécutif qui
prétendrait incarner la légitimité
populaire
donc elles servent à quelque chose s'est
vraiment je pense les fondations de la
démocratie qui sont ici en jeu c'est pas
une question de
valeurs conservatrices alors on a vu que
sa main pour rebondir sur ce que vous
venez de dire ce qui est intéressant
cancan sorbonne était à bruxelles
étaient reçus cohn bendit l'interpellé
vertement en le comparant non pas un
dirigeant de droite ou de droite dure ou
de droite de la droite mais en le
comparant à chavez maduro castro ce qui
est ce qui donne un peu le sens des
griefs et de la lente marche de son pays
vers quelque chose qui mute de la droite
vers une forme de populisme as
intrigante la hongrie c'est le
laboratoire de l'europe et à ce titre la
scor ban fait c'est de tester les
limites de bruxelles il ya une phase de
jeu et de test et il est en train de
voir jusqu'où ça tient jusqu où le
roseau plie est ce qu'il est ce qu'elle
va rompre ou pas pour répondre à votre
question parce que c'était un peu ça je
ressentais un peu le débat la question
cs korba nhs est un dirigeant de droite
et si on avait peu posé la question il
ya dix ans de ça après a priori non il
était très loin du territoire de la
droite telle qu'on la pensait il est dit
par contre hull et c'est ça que vous ils
n'étaient pas populiste est en tout cas
les méthodes n'étaient pas aussi défini
que maintenant quand on pose la question
maintenant il ressemble de plus en plus
c'est ce que la droite tend vers fin
vers ce que les dirigeants de droite
veulent être du coup oui ils leur
rendent dans le dans l'ue dans le giron
d'une certaine droite qui elle aussi
muté se pose des questions sur sur sur
ce qu'allait donc si entre guillemets il
se fait virer on peut se poser des
questions est ce que la droite se sépare
pas d'une partie et d'un hémisphère
assez important de ce qu'allait c'est
par exemple de l'ambiguïté qu'à c'est
défendre quelqu'un de connu c'est sûr
mais il est évident que par exemple pour
autre droite française prendre position
vis-à-vis
c'est une balise ce ça c'est un
épouvantail aussi pour certains mais
c'est une balise est un fardeau
donc là ça va être compliqué parce qu'au
sein des républicains wauquiez veut pas
qu'on le vire je crois bellamy non plus
quand y en a d'autres qui sont évoqués
étaient plutôt assez favorable à oman et
il est clair qu'une certaine partie d'un
électorat pourrait fuir vers d'autres
cieux s'il prenait ce genre d'imposition
c'est assez risqué
il faut aussi réponse se méfier d'urban
parce que l'europe est en crise il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
parce que si on laisse faire ce qu'il
veut faire évidemment au japon et
l'europe d'obtenir des concessions de ne
pas respecter les règles de l'union
européenne
il peut voit la porte a plein d'autres
pays vivement au ban a fait ceci peut
être que nous on faire la même chose et
déjà avec avec bon jeu placé pour le
savoir le break c'est dans la combe
bretagne ce qui se passe en italie
l'europe peut dégringoler vite fait et
je trouve que l'alternative n'est pas
très réjouissant et si on pense à mon
accompagna baise ce que j'avais est
devenu ce que vous allez zou et là ils
devenus moi c'est pas sérieux aujourd
hui sont non plus le mot de la fin
revient à monsieur babineau keita nos
internautes fidèles que vous le
connaissez tous et lui nous dit le
problème c'est que la droite classique
se fait engloutir par son bord
nationaliste et c'est inquiétant
il ne faut pas selon lui banaliser les
personnages comme hors bannu salvini
c'est dangereux même par la droite
et bien voilà cette diversité de points
de vue même chez ceux qui nous regardent
c'est ce qui fait la richesse de cette
émission on revient à l'actualité
français si ça vous va pour parler de
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur vous savez qu'il a été très
critiqué après le saccage des champs
elysées lors de la manifestation des
gilet jaune de samedi dernier un certain
nombre de dirigeants de la préfecture de
police de paris a commencé par le préfet
lui même ont été limogés
mais christophe castaner lui est
toujours là est ce que c'est normal
maintenant qu'on a un petit peu de recul
on va pouvoir y revenir écoutez d'abord
cette ce témoignage de marine le pen ou
plus exactement cette demande
pour elle c'est clair castanea doit s'en
aller au bout de combien de
manifestations où les casseurs casse
monsieur castaner va se dire il faut
peut-être que je présente ma démission
car manifestement je suis incapable de
remplir la tâche qui m'a été confiée au
combien faut-il de manifestations ce
qu'on en est à 18 c il en faut 20 22
alors il ya d'autres gens inquiets qui
demandent la la démission de christophe
castaner je vous propose de l'écouter
lui maintenant notamment dans cette
séquence que je trouve très intéressante
sur laquelle j'aimerais bien avoir votre
point de vue il était hier sur france
inter et en fait il a raconté presque en
confidence comment est ce qu'il a
découvert de façon assez inattendue que
la police n'avait pas forcément utiliser
les bonnes armes samedi dernier dimanche
matin j'étais au commissariat du viiième
rencontrer cette famille qui a été sauvé
par les policiers avec les policiers
avec les pompiers qui l'ont sauvé un des
policiers m'a pris à part
il m'a dit c'est mme smith c'est quand
même dommage qu'on ait pas le droit
d'utiliser la levée des limites où ça
vient je pensais même que c'était une
rumeur je trouve que lundi matin j'ai su
que ça n'était pas une rumeur de la
préfecture de police des consignes ont
été données qui ne sont pas remonter au
préfet de police
selon ce que m'a indiqué le préfet de
police et le préfet de police ne m'a pas
référé de quelque chose dont il n'avait
pas connaissance
voilà donc apparemment ni le ministre ni
le préfet de police est au courant que
les policiers n'utilisait pas les
lanceurs de balles de défense en tout
cas pas exactement les mêmes munitions
que lors des manifestations précédentes
laurent david samama est ce que vous
trouvez normal que christophe castaner
soit toujours à son poste dans un
contexte normal on peut penser qu'il
aurait
quitter son poste de lui-même ou donné
sa démission et je pense que c'est ce
que veulent et ce qu aurait voulu
souhaiter une partie de son propre camp
sauf qu'on n'est pas dans un contexte
normal et la macro ni adeus différent de
ce qu'on connaissait jusqu'à présent
castaner en partant et s'il partait
voudrait dire quelque chose et enverra
un message assez fort sur macro lui a
fallu lui même donc on peut penser qu'il
ya une sorte de duo tandem et que les
l'un et l'autre sont liés peu c'est peu
probable que l'un lâche l'autre mais on
rappellera que c'était le menu mâcon qui
avait voulu la nomination castaner
tandis que les voir philippe lui était
plutôt fixé casper qui est qui a fait
tout son possible pour avoir ce poste là
aussi nous avons lu voilà il ya ce
serait étonnant qu'il le quitte de
lui-même aussi fasse aussi rapidement
cabri avec l'usl est ce que selon vous
cassano a sauvé sa tête pour dire les
choses un peu con il a sauvé sa tête
freud y profite rarement on va dire ce
qui est certain et c'est un petit peu
paradoxal malgré tout c'est qu'on a eu
le sentiment durant tous ces actes
qu'ils étaient très proches du terrain
c'était un peu napoléon avant austerlitz
il passé en revue ses troupes au petit
matin
je me souviens des missions de d'image
très précise à la télévision donc on
sent très très proches
et puis ça dure et de tweets envoyés par
lui oui voilà vraiment sur le terrain
vont en fait c'était pas oesterlé
c'était peut-être waterloo mais le fait
est qu'il avait l'air très proches et et
le le problème est que là aujourd'hui
dilma finalement je n'étais pas au
courant
d'ailleurs c'est le préfet de police qui
a alors c'est vrai qu'on peut on peut
dire que c'est logique dans la chaîne de
commandement que ce soit lui qui saute
entre guillemets mais le fait est que
lui restait et puis l'était pas il
n'était pas là au début il n'a pas tout
compris on a fait des choses qu'il
n'avait pas décidé
je trouve que c'est une façon pas très
personnellement pas très digne de 2
de réagir sur ceux là dessus et puis il
ya un moment où ça fonctionnera plus
parce que c'est une carte que l'on joue
il faut un troquet une fois la question
twitter ben c'est celle constituée en
train de se poser sur ce plateau le
ministre at il sauvé sa tête notamment
après son audition au sénat
audition qui date d'hier vous nous
répondez non à 71% alors nicole nous dit
un petit peu en écho à ce que vous venez
de dia gabriel cluzel il a fait sauter
tous ses fusibles mais il est le vrai et
seul ou presque responsable